[Music]
the year 2020 has redefined how the
world interacts
moving us into a highly digital era
hosting a virtual event for the first
time can seem overwhelming
with over a decade of experience in
creating compelling virtual events
lab roots is uniquely qualified to guide
our clients in navigating this new
virtual culture
hosted on a powerful virtual platform in
html5
events are fully supported on all mobile
devices
while lab roots is known as the leading
scientific social community
and the world's largest producer of
scientific virtual events and webinars
we also specialize in tailor-made
client-branded virtual events in all
industries
we offer a collaborative and
personalized approach with a dedicated
team
assigned to ensure your vision is made a
reality
here's a snapshot of some of our key
features
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as we look to the future hybrid events
that combine both
in-person and virtual experiences will
be an essential part of the new norm
hybrid events extends your reach
transforms marketing strategies
and provides more comprehensive data
points whether you're hosting an
executive meeting or company event
emulating a physical trade show
experience or showcasing your products
we're here to make it happen the value
delivered in a physical event space is
maintained
just reimagined virtually with 3.7
million registrants and our turnkey
solutions
we understand storytelling and branding
lab roots is confident we can produce a
successful custom virtual event on our
platform for you